Speaker 1: A massive, cartoonish dramatic
episode has surfaced over the weekend because
NFL football player Aaron Rodgers, who's
the quarterback for the Green Bay Packers,
is in the middle of a COVID. I don't even know
what to call it. It's not really a scandal, it's
sort of like an episode of stupidity for lack of a
better term. It's a wild story. And quite frankly,
it's a reminder to us that there are dumb people
in this country, in all professions, in all walks
of life, with all educational backgrounds and of
all economic circumstances. So here's the story.
37 year old Aaron Rodgers tested positive for
COVID didn't play yesterday against the Kansas
City Chiefs great. He previously claimed to
have been immunized. Now, whatever he meant
by immunized, we now have learned he's not been
vaccinated against COVID 19. He says he's allergic
to the vaccines. He's taking ivermectin. He says
a woke mob has come after him. They're trying to
cancel him, per NBC. All of this different stuff
now before we get into the new material on this.
Here is Aaron Rodgers in August, when he was
asked, Have you been vaccinated? And has he says,
I've been immunized, which, OK, we'll talk about
in a second. Take a look at this in conversation.
Speaker 4: Are you vaccinated and what's your
stance on vaccinations? Yeah, I've been immunized.
You know, there's a lot of a lot of conversation
around it around the league and a lot of guys who
have made statements and have made statements,
owners have made statements, right? You know,
those guys on the team that haven't been
vaccinated. I think it's a personal decision.
I'm not going to judge those guys. There's guys
who've been vaccinated who contracted COVID.
Speaker 1: So, OK. So that was August 26. Then, he
says, I've been immunized. We, of course, are now
learning among certain people immunized means very
different things. There are people who say, Well,
I haven't been vaccinated, but I was sick with
COVID. So now I'm immune. There are other people.
You go further down the rabbit holes, right, who
say, I took ivermectin and received antibodies
and as if there are mice in and so now I'm immune.
OK, so he maybe was just lying or he believed he
had been immunized through some other means.
It's not really clear. So then we get to this
weekend. He's positive for COVID, he's not playing
yesterday, etc. He appears on the Pat McAfee Show
sports analyst, podcaster, pro-wrestler, color
commentator, former football punter OK, Pat McAfee
and Rogers says, Well, you know, I've been
getting medical advice from Joe Rogan's podcast
and from Joe Rogan on the phone personally and
pay attention in this clip. If you're watching
Pat McAfee, who's on the left, can barely
contain his laughter. It's it's actually it's
quite something here. Let's take a look.
Speaker 4: And
I consulted with a now good friend of mine, Joe
Rogan, after he got Colon, and I've been doing
a lot of this stuff that he recommended in his
podcasts. And, you know, on the phone to me, and
I'm going to have the best immunity possible
now, based on the two point five million
person study from Israel and the people who get
COVID and recover have the most robust immunity.
And I'm thankful for people like Joe stepping
up and using their voice. I'm thankful my
medical squad and I'm full for people like Joe
stepping up and using their voice. I'm thankful
my medical squad just repeated there.
Speaker 1: For some reason. I don't know
Speaker 4: why, and I'm thankful for
all the love and support I've gotten,
but I've been taking monoclonal antibodies,
ivermectin, zinc, vitamin C and H.Q. HQ and
I feel pretty incredible.
Speaker 1: OK,
it's it's fine actually to get advice from
friends about their experiences, right? Like if I.
Tested positive for COVID. I would also
go and talk to friends. What what was the
progression of your symptoms and where that's not
inherently bad, but coming up with the view that
you got from Joe Rogan, which is counter to ninety
nine point ninety nine percent of medical science
lying, or who knows what you meant
when you said, I've been immunized
and then you say this, you don't look particularly
smart, I think is the point I'm trying to make.
And Rogers has described himself as a critical
thinker. He said at another point during this
interview, which I encourage you to check out,
he said that he put together a 500 page. Set of
research of some kind which he gave to the NFL and
Pat McAfee asked him, How did the NFL responded?
And Roger said, Well, they they acted like I was
a quack, and he at one point actually mentions
that you heard him say they're going to have
the best immunity. And later in the interview,
he explained, You know, look at the Israeli
study, which says recovering from COVID gives
you better immunity than getting the vaccine.
OK, let's actually let's let's look Oh no,
I'm not going to play a clip for that, but you
can find that clip. So a lot of people have been
mentioning that. What about that Israeli study?
Does it actually say that you're better protected
if you recover rather than being vaccinated?
Rodgers is repeating it. Others are repeating
it. It's not actually what the study says.
What the Israeli study says is, first of all,
if you recovered from COVID on average,
you're more protected against Delta, then from
only being vaccinated. And that appears to be
true. In particular, if you've been infected more
recently by a strain more similar to Delta, it
appears that you are more protected against Delta
if you recover from the virus rather than only
get vaccinated in the short term, at least. And
that kind of makes sense, right? The vaccines were
developed to tackle the original or live variant
at some point. Maybe soon we're going to have a
vaccine that's actually tailored to Delta or newer
variants, but the vaccines were developed based
on the 2020 live original variant. So if you're
infected more recently and the vast majority
of the infections have been more recent than
from when the vaccine was developed, it's
logical that your current protection against
the current strain might be stronger.
However, if you look at the Israeli study,
it also says COVID recovery plus vaccine gives you
the best protection, the best protection overall.
So wouldn't you want that given the option between
recovery or recovery plus vaccine, which gives you
better protection? I would want recovery plus
vaccine, and my preference would actually be not
to get the virus at all. Also, that study is from
August. It was published in August, and it's based
on data slightly before that. The virus continues
to change, and there's a real question as to how
recent infection would compare to vaccination by
next fall, for example. So as usual, a little bit
of knowledge can be a very dangerous thing. All
right now, there's a ton of stuff we could look at
here. Here's another short clip where Roger
says no one wants to admit ivermectin works
because there's no money in ivermectin,
which is not true. But he almost stumbles
upon something with a grain of truth.
Speaker 4: If you're a healthy person.
We have a strong immune system to build your
immune system and and do what you have to do,
do what's best for your body. But that opinion,
you know, doesn't work because. We, you know,
we you know, we've given away billions of dollars
to these pharmaceutical companies now for these
for these vaccines, and it's not going
to stop Merck's coming out with a pill.
You know, Pfizer's coming out with a pill that's
going to help, you know, it's basically the
expensive versions of ivermectin. Why don't treat
ivermectin? That's because Trump championed it
because cheap generic can make any money off it.
But it's been used a billion times in India. Look
at that research. What's going on with it? Yeah.
Speaker 1: So we've heard none of these are new
talking points. These are all talking points we're
familiar with. The thing he gets close to is.
The reason that cheap, generic stuff
like ivermectin is tried against COVID is
you've got a new disease, you've got people
dying, you don't yet have vaccines, you don't
yet really have treatments. So what do you do you
see? Does anything I have that's cheap work. OK,
so the right analysis is and we've
talked about it before with doctors,
you're sitting around, you go, What do we do?
OK, let's try hydroxychloroquine. Let's try
ivermectin. It's cheap. Let's try as they throw
mice and let's try zinc. Let's do vitamin D.
The fact that it's cheap, generic stuff is
why it gets tried absent a known immunization
or treatment that's been studied further. But this
stuff has been tested, and I wish ivermectin was
shown to work in randomized, controlled placebo
trials. I wish it was. It would be fantastic, but
it hasn't. So he almost stumbles upon something
that's like sort of true, but he just then goes
completely off the rails. So this is really sad
because these are the same opinions as lots of
people on Facebook have maybe your crazy uncle or
whatever. But this is someone that is considered
a quote role model by society. Not saying
you should be, but he is. And unfortunately,
a lot of people listen to what he has to say. So
send me your thoughts. We'll have more on this
Aaron Rodgers fiasco on our Instagram,
which you can find at David Pakman show.